[Musique]
alors elle arrive maintenant parce que
on commence à ça fait quand même pas mal
de moi qu'on est dans cette épidémie et
qu'on essaye d'adapter les mesures avec
un compromis entre les dimensions
sanitaires mais aussi les dimensions
économique et sociale et que on souhaite
bien trouver le juste milieu voilà qui
permettent on va dire de faire éviter
que cette épidémie de fleurs mais en
même temps qu'elles ne réduisent pas
complètement notre économie comme on l'a
vécu l'année dernière
donc voilà donc on essaye d'adapter aux
réalités locales donc fait une demande
forte déjà depuis quelques temps pour
pouvoir stabiliser peut-être plus les
acteurs de terrain qui sont en demande
de participer à cette politique est
d'adapter en fonction des différents
contextes
il faut obtenir quelques mois pas plus
normalement les choses devraient
s'éclaircir et on peut parler de
l'immunité qui va installer
progressivement nos pays dont il faut
dire que ça sur le fond mme hrc d'accord
avec ce qui est fait on peut toujours
discuter les détails et c'est vrai vous
avez raison les gens commencent plus en
plus mal que les règles et contraintes
mais de l'autre côté c'est vital parce
qu'on peut pas non plus habitués à 400
morts par jour disant bon bon c'est
comme ça c'est compliqué oui je voulais
juste a ajouté qu'il y avait quand même
une grande différence aussi au delà du
vaccin c'est qu'on a quand même beaucoup
plus beauty poursuivre cette épidémie
par rapport à tous ces tests de
dépistage en plus qu'on est capable
d'identifier les variants voilà donc on
suit de plus près le voile année
l'épidémie ce qui n'était pas le cas au
tout début
tant qu'on est à des niveaux assez
élevés comme aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
appliquer toutes les mesures qui
devraient découler des tests parce
qu'ils sont on a trop de positif
mais c'est vrai que si on arrive à
gratter cette famille là 15,8 à 10000
encore mieux à 5100 voilà on a des
stratégies qui seront très fortes
bon maintenant mais vous avez raison le
fait de pouvoir tester à grande échelle
elle les eaux usées qui sont très
importantes qui donne des indications
sur ce qui se passe dans les régions
donc on a beaucoup de moyens qu'on
n'avait pas on n'avait pas six mois
[Musique]
il se trouve que j'ai fait une enquête
sur les dynamiques territoriales ennuis
avec l'aco vite je travaille sur la
manière dont on accompagne on soigne les
personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées sur les territoires moi ce
que j'ai repéré c'est que les acteurs
qui avaient été les plus est dans en
facilitant c'est vraiment les acteurs de
proximité c'est les collectivités
locales c'est donc les départements etc
les antennes départementales des agences
régionales de santé
je pense que on a besoin d'avoir cette
proximité pour avoir une action efficace
pour être aussi en soutien aux la
d'acteur on va dire du promoteur
d'action sur les territoires et on se
rend compte que voilà le c'est très
compliqué de gérer un pays dans sa
diversité
totalement depuis paris pour prendre ce
genre de décision il faut tenir compte
des conditions locales des différents
d'une ville dans une grande une petite
ville cetera mais il faut tenir compte
également des données épidémiologiques
et scientifique que n'a pas forcément le
maire d'une petite commune même d'une
moyenne commune
il peut avoir des conseillers mais quand
même il ya un élément de réflexion sans
tomber dans le problème les pouvoirs de
la chanson mais il ya quand même les
deux éléments mial éléments que la
vision épidémiologique et scientifique
du problème et les problèmes humains
liés aux activités de chacun et je pense
que effectivement c'est un progrès qu'il
y ait une relation de plus en plus
proche entre les pouvoirs publics entre
gouvernement et les pouvoirs locaux
[Musique]
frontier deux tibias de niveau de
solidarité il ya la solidarité nationale
et la solidarité internationale
les deux sont très importants et un peu
différent ou assez différent au niveau
national
il faut que chacun comprenne que il doit
aider les autres régions ne peut se
faire par des transferts de malades en
réanimation
ça peut faire justement avec une
discipline de déplacement même si c'est
pas imposés comme des bananes bloc des
gens réfléchissent un petit peu à leurs
déplacements par année dans un esprit de
solidarité sas est premiers éléments il
ya autour niveau international s'était
beaucoup discuté depuis un mois je vais
partir on a beaucoup réfléchi et c'est
repris par thoune aurait tous d'accord
sur le fond savoir comment le faire
comment faire arriver les vaccins dans
tous les pays du monde où tous les pays
où c'est nécessaire et là il ya
d'énormes problèmes de solidarité qui
compliquait par des problèmes légaux sur
les brevets et là c'est un enjeu majeur
qui va être l'objet de beaucoup de
discussions dans les mois à venir il ya
des territoires qui sont moins bien
pourvues en offre un donc par exemple on
parle des déserts médicaux
donc c'est aussi d'avoir des équipes
mobiles qui peuvent aller aider pour les
vaccinations pour le dépistage 1 sans
parler des transferts pour les
hospitalisations donc ça c'est du coin
du sanitaire après du point de vue on va
dire social c'est voilà les aides
financières peut-être c'est ce que vous
écoutez leur peuvent être répartis de
manière équitable en fonction des
besoins en attendant ça a beaucoup parlé
de la france
le problème il est quand même mondiale
il faut pas l'oublier
on est tous dépendants les uns des
autres on l'a vu pour l'accès ou aux
masques aux différents produits
maintenant au vaccin
et effectivement on a tous intérêt à ce
que tout le monde soit soient vaccinés
et soit à soigner au mieux et là on a
vraiment des gros progrès à parce que
sinon c'est ce virus il va continuer à
développer à faire des nouveaux variants
qui peut être et chaque roue au vaccin
et ça risque d'être très compliqué dans
la durée